Good morning.
Good morning to Good morning, sir. Morning. Morning, sir.
Good morning, sir. Good morning.
We start in another one
or two minutes, just set up the thing.
Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good morning.
Okay, now let me share my screen.
Okay, so last class
and last to last classes, we,
we were talking about the sequence to sequence modeling.
I started with the sequence to sequence modeling,
and in the last class, we had also seen some demo of
that sequence to sequence modeling.
Okay, so now we are moving ahead
with the attention mechanism.
So, okay, let's start with this.
So, uh, we understood, right, the, the, the
sequence to sequence modeling why it is required
and why the, the kind
of problem which was, uh, solved by the sequence
to sequence modeling was not able to solve by any other,
other architectures like RN and L-S-T-M-G-R-U alone.
Okay? So, because now we have the two different sequences
and input also, we have sequence
or put also we have sequence.
And those two sequence length is not same.
If their length are same, then we,
we may not require sequence to sequence architecture.
We may do only with one of the LST architecture.
Uh, and, and we can do that
because for every time a stem, if it is fixed
that we are having only one
output, then there is no problem.
Okay? But the problem here is
that input sequence length would be different.
Output sequence length would be different.
Hence, for every LSTM, I can't have a single output.
And that's why we need a separate architecture encoder,
which will encode the input,
and then we can do the decode, which can then generate
as many outputs as you want in the, in the
timestamp manner, right?
So this was the main idea of
the sequence to sequence modeling.
And, uh, the limitation
of this particular approach was again, the,
we talked about this, uh, scenario
where suppose we have our context is very long, okay?
And the scenario is that you have
to do the machine translation case.
Then what this, uh, encoder was trying to do
that it was reading the entire paragraph at once, trying to
give, give, give one context vector,
a fixed length context vector, say 2 56 dimension,
five 12 dimension vector.
And that vector was responsible
for remembering everything here.
Okay? That was the, that was the responsibility
of this context vector.
Then, uh, uh, what was happening at the decoder side,
that the decoded side, we were taking this context vector,
and then at timestamped manner, we were trying to
generate the, uh, word in the,
in the corresponding language,
whatever language here, it was Hindi.
So the problem, you can see, right?
The problem is we are giving a huge responsibility to this,
to this context vector.
That is one thing From the encoded side,
there's a huge responsibility which is given
to the context vector, right?
And, uh, which is, which is, uh, which is fine,
but then it, there, there is a high chance
that it'll not do that.
It'll not remember a hundred percent
because LSTM have a architecture
that it has to forget something.
It have, it will add something, all those things, right?
So it might, might miss some of the details.
There is just chances of that.
Now, uh, suppose the context vector doesn't lose anything
and keep all the information of the encoder.
That is, that is also the one of the cases you can expect.
But the problem with the decoder side is
that the same context vector was we were feeding to each
of the, this the LSTM network, LSTM cells at the,
in the decoder timestamps, right?
So context vector, which was there at the zero timestamp,
and, uh, the same context factor, obviously
with some modification going to the, uh, first time stem,
second time stem, third and fourth and so on.
So, what was happening is
because for every time stem, we had
to predict the different word, right?
And obviously we were feeding the current input,
but then the previous timestamp, whatever output was coming,
the context vector that was not changing much, okay?
There was a slight change,
but this context vector was almost same.
The same context factor is used at every decoding step
with some modification, obviously,
because you, at every LM cell,
you add something and you delete something.
So decoder cannot focus on the relevant source words.
That was the main problem.
That for, for the word meh, the encoder I is important,
and m and going is not important.
But that was not told by the context vector.
That is the problem. If the context vector along
with this context factor, we also have some,
another context factor,
or you can say that some other attention, which can say
that I is important m and going is not important.
Then it had, it would've been easy for these LS tian cells
to predict the next word in the corresponding language.
But that was not happening.
That is not happening in the case
of sequence to sequence modeling.
And it'll, it'll lead
to the in character generic translation.
But that was the main problem.
We talked about it, and hence we arrived at the solution
of this particular problem as attention.
We say that once we have, say
that this is the whole document, right?
And before, uh, giving this document to the decoder,
the encoder has to encode everything.
So encoder will encode everything.
But at the decoder, every time, aamp, somehow we need
to find span of words or word, word
or a span of word, a single word, or together multiple words
or at different places, also some words.
So yeah, what we are trying to do here is we are trying
to find that, okay, in the whole, whole paragraph
or whole document, what are the words which are important
at a particular timestamp of the Dakota?
And hence, give more weight to those words only, okay?
And let us not give equal weight to the entire document.
So not all inputs are equally important.
That is what is the most important thing,
what attention said, maybe only at every time stamp
of the decoder, because decoder will work at a
timestamp manner, right?
So at every time,
stamp only few words are important in the encoder,
let us find that few words, which are important
and will give that to the decoder so
that decoder can then generate the next word accordingly.
Okay? That will be more helpful,
rather than giving every time the entire document.
Okay? So this is, this was the main idea of the attention.
So now I'll, I'll just walk you through the attention
and I will just explain you today, uh, the mayor today, uh,
that, uh, what is the, uh, how,
how exactly the attention is being calculated.
First, I'll talk in general,
but then I will also talk about one
or two famous type of attention mechanism, like, uh,
we'll talk about the au attention as well
as the long attention.
There are many other attention mechanism also, which has,
which was proposed in the same duration,
but then this attention was the first one who attempted it.
And long attention is another way of doing the attention.
So we'll talk about these two, right, in this,
this particular class today.
So before I'll proceed if you have any query.
So let me know, then I'll just start
No queries, sir.
Okay, fine. Thank you. Alright.
So let us then walk through the attention that
how exactly it is calculated,
because one thing we have understood
that ev every time a stamp of the decode, we want to tell
to these LSTM cells somehow that, okay, I is important,
say 80%, um, or I is important.
M and going is not that much important. Okay?
Similarly, at the second time stamp,
I might be interested in saying, going is important
because ja raha both are coming from the word going right?
Almost. So going is important, but I
and m is not that much important.
So similarly, at the third time stamp,
I'm saying going is important, I
and m is not that much important maybe,
or, uh, similarly, in the third time, fourth time stamp,
I'm saying that, okay, this m is important.
I, and going is not important that much.
And finally, we are closing it.
So this is how somehow we have to tell
to the decoder at every time, stamp that, okay,
this word in the encoder is important
for doing the translation at this particular
time stamp of the decode.
Okay? Once we give that information,
then there is no problem for the Dakota.
It can easily compute, uh, again, with the help of the LSTs
or some feedforward neural network, something it'll do,
but somehow it'll compute that, okay, what is the next
Hindi word, which I have
to give at this particular time of step?
Okay, so now let us see that, how to do that.
So before that, let us understand that at every, uh,
at every timestamp of the decoder, okay?
Decoder every timestamp,
although I'm showing you everything together,
but actually this is the first time it'll come.
Then second, then third, then fourth, then fifth,
we have talked about it, right?
Sequence to sequence modeling the, uh, training time
and the inference time.
In the training time, uh, or the inference time.
What happens basically
that the decoder decoder always works, uh, uh,
as a auto aggressive manner, okay?
Auto aggressive manner in the sense it takes the input
so far, whatever it has, uh, it has,
and then predict the next word.
And then it takes the, for example, when you start
with the start, then it gives the map the next time a start
and map together gives ja then a start, maja gives raha.
And so on the auto design, that is how the sequence
to sequence model works at the, uh, inference time.
So we have already talked about that.
So now let us see that at every time stamp of the decoder,
we should focus on only a few relevant words in theod,
for example, in the timestamp one, okay?
Or I should have told it is zero
because whatever, why I am saying zero,
because at this particular timestamp, the input,
what I'm giving it is not generated input, right?
Start. Okay? The start is something which we simply, uh,
start with at the zero timestamp.
So, uh, uh, suppose it's a timestamp zero,
which I'll create from next time, but that here it is, uh,
or it is timestamp one, just imagine that, just a,
a matter of notation.
So suppose is timestamp, step one,
where the start is an input.
So this LSTM, it takes the context vector,
and it also takes the say that embedding of this start
or one hot vector of the start here, correct?
Now, based on these two, these two things, it has to tell,
it has to tell that this word, which it has to get
as an output is man,
but it would've been better than that.
We would've said that along with these two, uh, we,
we would've also said that focus on I.
Now, this is what we have to model, okay?
This is what we have to model. Now, how do we model that?
I'll explain you later, but this is what I'm trying to do.
I'll, I will not change in this architecture or anything.
I'll still give context factor as an input
because it has the overall context of this.
I am going, right?
So context vector will go as it is, as an input
to the TM in the Dakota, every time a stamp,
it will also have its own input.
Like a start is an input here, along with these two,
I'll say focus on I, okay,
now, this is what I have to model.
I'll tell you how now that
that will happen at the time stamp number one, similarly,
at the time, stamp number two.
Now what? I'll say that, okay, focus on going,
because now I have to give Ja, so I have to say,
somehow I have to model it somehow that,
now I'll tell this lst m that you have
to focus on the word going similarly,
at the third timestamp, I'll say, okay,
focus on going still.
Maybe at the fourth timestamp, I'll say focus on m
and then at the fifth timestamp, it will end.
So no strong focus on any new word.
Now see this focus on, I focus on going, this is
what I'm going to model, model.
When I say I'm going to do some mathematical, uh,
calculation in order to get that focus.
And that itself is known as attention.
So attention, we are going to calculate at every time stamp
of the decoder, okay?
It's not a single attention, which will, which will work
for the entire decoder.
So at every time stamp of the decoder, we'll have one,
one attention, okay?
And that is how we'll have one extra edge,
and hence the same architecture.
Having that attention in consideration will definitely
improve because the, the logic looks correct.
Now, how do we implement the logic? Let us see that.
So instead of one fixed context vector,
we dynamically compute context at every time stamp.
So this common context vector, we also dynamically compute
the context vector at every timestamp, which will say,
okay, focus on this word.
Focus on this word right now.
So how do we model it? It's all about that, okay?
How do we come up with some mechanisms so that I can, uh,
tell the focus on this particular word?
Okay? That is what we have to understand now.
So let us understand that what changes with attention, okay?
Because we have seen that in the case of, uh, uh,
standard encoder decoder,
and I'm only talking about now decoder encoder.
We know how does it work? There is no change in the encoder.
So our focus is on decoder that how does it work?
So in the standard encoder decoder is sequence
to sequence model what happened at the decoder.
If you see what happened, step number one, step number one,
you feed Y node and you feed S minus one.
Okay? So this should have been the S minus one.
Uh, one second.
Uh, this should have been the S
minus one, okay?
I, I'll change it anyway,
but I thought that the, these,
these three things and minus
one, it should be because I, I starting with, um,
I have not yet started anything.
The minus one. Why I am saying that
because, uh, nothing is coming from the second,
sorry, this should be zero,
and this should be one,
minus one, then zero, then one, and then so on, right?
Okay, so little run. So what happens?
So at the first time, stamp of the, uh, decoder you feed,
why not, which is the current input.
That is called start, start.
Uh, one hot vector is shown here as Y not,
and S minus one is nothing
but this context vector,
which is coming from the encoder site.
Okay? So, so that is at the first time stamp.
Now, now at the second time stamp, what happened?
It is Y one, S one, Y one,
and uh,
yeah, thank you.
Okay, so S minus one.
And then at the first trimester,
what happened is Y one s not,
and at second trimester, what happened is Y two S one,
and we know that what happened inside this lium, right?
That, that, that idea we already have,
we get the two inputs,
and then we do all those gates calculations, right?
We calculate the fargate gate,
input gate output gate, all those things we do.
Now that, that already, we know that we are not going, going
inside, but this is a usual multiplication or mathematical,
or you can say that the input which we give at every time,
a stamp of the decoder, the current input
and the last hidden output,
these are the two inputs right now.
What changes With the attention? With the attention.
Now, what happened along with this? Why not?
And S minus one, we are also going to give something
as an attention that is gonna say C note.
Okay? Now, this is a change.
How do we calculate the C note that we are going
to see in the entire, uh, lecture
or entire class Today, we are going to talk more,
more on the c, no, C one and C two itself,
but that is what we talked, right?
Somehow the C no should say at the first time, a stem
that focus on I or you give more waiters to this word I.
That is what this C no has to say, okay?
Similarly, at the second time, stem along with this Y one,
and as as note, which is coming from last head state,
as well as the current input, I have to say C one.
C one is a attention score.
Attention score, which will say that, okay,
focus on the word going similarly at the third timestamp.
C two will say, focus on the word going. Okay?
Now this is what is the change which we are trying to bring,
bring with the attention, okay?
In the same setup. In the same setup,
this will be the change.
Right? Now, let us see how to do that change.
So context vector ct, which represent here, C, no, C one ct,
change it at every time.
Tamp here, that is also very important.
The C node, what you get at the first time, tamp
and C one, what you get a second timestamp.
Both are different. They're not same.
And that's, so if they're same, then there is no,
there is no benefit, right?
They should dynamically change with the timestamp,
how it is growing, and at every time stem it say that,
which word to focus in the encoder.
That is the main logic of that attention. Okay?
Now, let us see that. So first of all, uh,
before going to see that, okay, what is the C node, C one
and C two, and how do we calculate that?
Let us understand that, that this c no, C one, C two,
which is represented here by ct,
whether it should be a vector, it should be a scaler,
or it should be a metrics,
because this is how you represent your input always, right?
Sometimes you represent the input as a scaler.
Uh, some, uh, like weights are a scaler.
Uh, biases are a scalers bias values a scaler, okay?
Sometimes you represent, uh, the, the features also
as a scaler, uh, entity, right?
But sometimes, uh, the, the input can be vectors also.
Like this start is a vector. Ma is a vector. Ja is a vector.
Likewise, right? So
likewise, you, uh, all
of you think can tell me whether this COC one, C two, it has
to be scaler or vector, or it has to be metrics.
What it has to be,
It should be, It should be vector.
Vector, right? Yeah. So it should be vector, right?
Vector, yes, vector. Correct. Why?
Because, uh, why, why vector? The point is why vector?
Because see it, I don't want here to give one, one value,
and that value scaler means what?
A single value, a single value means what?
It'll say that, okay, the word I is important, maybe that,
that, that is the chances right here.
It may say that going is important here.
It can say the going is important, that
that scale at which I will feed.
But you know, sometimes it may happen that, uh,
for a particular word, translation, it is possible that
for that particular word, translation,
there are two words in the encoder are, are playing, uh,
playing a role, okay?
For example, see the same word going, okay,
going is important maybe for this, this second timestamp,
but maybe m going
or uh, m going maybe important for the word.
Uh, third, second, uh, third time stamp,
or 1, 2, 3, third time step.
So what I'm trying to say is
every time the translation is not word to word, okay?
It is possible that two words together is making a
translation into the different language, okay?
So I can't be only concentrating on the word I
or only concentrating on the word m
and only concentrating on the word going.
So what I'm trying to say is
obviously I'll have more focus on I
as compared to mgo.
Similarly, I'll have more focus on going maybe as compared
to I and m likewise,
but that focus should be given to all means,
unless I don't compute the attention with each of these,
how to know that, okay,
how much focus I have to give to each of them.
So what I'm trying to say is here, once again,
to make it more clear, for every time stamp of the decoder,
I'll compute the attention, I'll compute the attention
with every timestamp of the encoder.
Like for this timestamp as not is an output, right?
So here, suppose I have, uh, sno,
so sno and snot
these two attention I'll calculate, okay,
these two attention I'll calculate similarly,
SNO H one attention,
I'll calculate Sno h two attention I'll calculate,
and then I'll get to know that, okay, how much it is to give
to this, how much it is to give this and how much,
and I can easily keep the soft max to come up
with a probability distribution.
So that we'll have, if we sum up all the three, I'll get one
in that way, I'm going to work, right?
So I, so this, first of all, let us understand the ct,
which I'm showing that, okay,
I'll give another input at each time.
Stamp of the decoder.
It is not going to be the scaler,
it is going to be the vector.
And what will be the dimension of the vector.
Dimension of the vector C, no, C one,
C two will be equivalent to
how many times stamp you have in the encoder.
If there are three, like SOS one, s two, the C,
no dimension will be three
because C no will have three value.
One value, which will say the weight is of high.
Second value will give the weightage of m
and third value will give the weight is of, uh,
going similarly, C one will also have three value.
Weight is of i, weight is of m, weight is of going.
C two will also have three values.
So C nine, C one, C two is a vector, it's not a scaler,
and it is not also the metrics, okay?
It's a vector which will have the weight
of every word in the encoder.
And obviously some weight will be higher,
some other weight will be lower.
And it's possible that for going, I have, uh, 60%
for MI have 30%, and for I have 10% together.
It is one ative distribution. All those things are possible.
So I'm not only concentrating on a single word,
but I'm giving the weight is to each
of the word in the encoder.
In that way, I'm also giving some weight to m
and giving very less weight to y.
When I'm doing the translation at the, the say
that the second time stamp and third time stamp,
likewise, it is going to work.
So yeah. So first of all, CT is a vector
and represents the way it is of every encoder timestamp.
Okay? Let us be very clear
with this particular statement now.
So yeah, this, I've already told.
Encoder has hidden states h not H one,
S two at every time stem.
These were the, uh, you can say that the output,
in fact, this should have been H one, right?
Because the output, what going here,
same output is going here also.
So there is some, some
mismatch, but you can understand, right?
Each, in each decoder step computes a different
weight distribution.
Therefore, CT must, depends on all encoded state
that I have already told, not let us see that.
Now it's, it's like, okay, how
to compute the ct CT we have understood, right?
So ultimately what we are going to do is we are going
to calculate the CT like C one, C two, C3,
likewise at every time a stamp of the decode,
and we are going to feed it
as an input tool each time stamp.
So C one, C two, C3, these are, they are all the vector.
That is what we have to understand.
Now, how do we calculate the city now? Uh, right?
So now we are going to see how do we calculate it.
So what we are going, uh, what exactly we want is we have
to give the waiters to this H one, S two, and S3.
Here it is corrected. You can see that H one is output
and H one is output.
Going to the next LSTM also S two is an output,
and S two is going the output to the next LSTM state also.
So likewise, so now we have to give some is to H one,
some weight to H two, some weight
to H three at E each time a stamp of the decode.
And that's how we'll calculate the C one.
That's how we'll calculate the C one.
So now you can see here, so, so
that weight is weight is how much I have to give.
That itself is your attention, okay?
That itself is attention.
So how much attention to give to the H one,
how much attention to give to the H two and S3,
and that is being represented here by alpha one, one,
alpha one, two, and alpha one three.
So what I'm doing is I'm just doing the weighted
calculation, weighted sum that, okay?
Alpha one, one into H one.
Now this is the weightage for the H one,
but remember H one is H one is
not a scaler.
H one is a vector. Remember,
because inside the elastic you have the neural
network, right?
And inside the neural network, the number
of neurons you have, that will, that will be the dimension
of this H one and this H one, okay?
So H one, what, when I say it is not a
scaler, this is also a vector.
And this alpha one, one alpha, one, two, alpha one, three,
this is, this is your, you can say that the scaler value,
this alpha one, one alpha one, two, alpha,
one, three, just scaler value.
Okay? So, but we need, so
because it is a weight, it is a weight.
So this weight is for H one, this weightage is for H two,
and this weightage is for H three.
And then what we are going to do is we are going
to concatenate all of them.
So plus you can see plus, plus plus.
So this, uh, scaler gets multiplied with a vector H one
and you, it gives you a vector itself.
And then here also alpha one, two is a, uh, scaler.
S two is a vector. You get a vector alpha one three scaler,
S 3G vector, you get a vector.
So vector plus vector plus vector, you get another vector.
And that itself will be the C one, which will go as an input
to this particular time stamp of the,
alright, so this is how we, we calculate it.
Now the bigger question is how does this alpha one,
one alpha one, two alpha one three is being
calculated, right?
But I guess you have understood this one, right?
So suppose we calculate this alpha one one,
which is a attention, which is attention score.
Then we can easily give, just multiply that
with the H one S two S3
accordingly with alpha 1, 1, 1, 2, 1 3.
And then we can add them together
and get the C one, which I'll feed it here.
Then I will have three inputs to this LSTM Y one as not.
Anyway, it was coming. C one will also be as an input,
third input to this lstm.
And we do the calculation
as we were doing earlier with the LST.
There is no change in that.
Only thing is now we have three inputs.
So we'll have three weights, three set of weights,
one set of weights for S node.
One is per Y 1, 1 1 will be per C one.
Okay? We'll talk about how to calculate the alpha one,
one alpha one, two, and alpha one three
right now, let us see.
Similarly, we are going to do it for C two also.
So now in the case of C two, now what will happen, this, uh,
will calculate alpha two one, alpha two, two, alpha two,
three, uh, because it's a different attention score, right?
So I'm just representing it by two one
because the second time stamp in the Dakota.
So C two would be calculated here, not here.
C two would be calculated here,
C one I have shown with this diagram.
But you can imagine, right?
Same thing will happen for C two also, C two would be,
so you will have three attention score, alpha two,
one alpha two, two alpha, two three,
and that you'll multiply with same H one s two S3
of the encoder, and you'll get C two and C two.
You'll feed here similarly, C3, similarly C four,
and as many Cs you have.
It depends on how many timestamp you have in the Dakota.
So ct, um, ct, uh, this is, this is
how you're going to calculate the ct.
So CT in general is represented like that. Okay?
So CT in general will be, I value is going from one
to three, say from the third time stamp, okay?
Or for, right? So I value is one timestamp.
You have to see what is the time stamp.
So suppose you are at one, okay?
Suppose you are at one, so it'll be 1, 1, 1, 2, 1 3.
Why this three? Uh, why it ivy is going from one
to three because, huh?
One more thing to just clarify.
The, I represent the encoder timestamp.
I represent the encoder timestamp,
and t represents the decoder timestamp, okay?
I represent the encoder timestamp.
T represents the decoder timestamp.
So in the encoder, I have three timestamp.
So I is going from one to three
and T depends on which, uh,
timestamp you are in the decoder.
Suppose you're at one, it'll be 1, 1, 1, 2, 1 3,
like it is shown here if you're at two, okay?
Then it'll be 2, 1, 2, 2, 2, 3.
So you'll get alpha two, one, alpha two, two alpha, two,
three, and that you're going to multiply with the each
of the H one, S two and S3.
That's why HI is being multiplied with alpha TI. Okay?
So, so this is a general representation of any, uh,
attention, uh, uh, calculation, right?
So dimension, as I have already told,
alpha ti this alpha one, one alpha, one, two, alpha one,
three is, it is going to be the scale.
This h, H one, S two, H three in general.
Hi, it is a vector.
And what will be the dimension of this H one,
H two depends on what, what is the dimension you have chosen
for this L sst m uh, inside we have multiple gates, right?
Neural networks. So whatever is this hidden size dimension,
that will be the dimension of this H one, H two S3.
So it's the vector. It's a vector.
So ultimately what you,
you are doing is you're multiplying a vector with a scaler.
So what ct, C one, C two, C3, whatever you will get, all
of them will be a vector, okay?
So, uh, this, this clarity should be there,
otherwise you will not get the okay how it is doing.
So, C one has to be a vector. There is no other way.
And how we are getting a vector, H one, S two,
S3 gene vector, you get the tension, multiply it with
that vector, add all of them, get the ct, that's all.
Okay? So CT is a weighted combination
of encoded hidden state.
Now the main question, which is still remaining, is how
to calculate this alpha T comma.
I like alpha one, one alpha one, two, alpha one three
or alpha 2, 1, 2, 2, 2, 3.
How to calculate these attentions
because these are the actual attention
and then we do some other, uh, multiplication
and addition to get the C one, C two, right?
Uh, so, but this, this, this is the, um,
attention what we have.
So let us now focus on alpha tcom.
Sir, one question. Sorry sir.
Yes, please, please. Yeah,
Sir, this, um, when we say, uh,
suppose we are calculating C one at the encoder, then at
that time, all the three at that end quarter timestamp,
all the three I am going,
all the three are inputs are given, or
because we are at C one, then only I is given
All the three. That's what it
is saying. Okay? All the three is given.
That's why H one S two, S3 is here.
H one, S two, S3 H one represents for IS two is an output
for m and S3 is an output for coin.
Okay? So these inputs
that the encoder are given at the same time,
Uh, yes, at the same time.
At the same time, yeah, you have to give, you have
to get all the three, uh, of these
and then you have to add them.
So you must have all these, yeah.
So sir, there will be comp,
like we are only showing C one in this diagram.
Mm-hmm. But, uh, C one will be calculated, say at timestamp,
T one or whatever, one timestamp, correct?
Then C two will be time calculated at the next timestamp
because these alphas will change,
Correct? Correct,
Correct. Okay.
Okay, sir. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you.
Alright, sir. Yeah, please, please.
Uh, sir, actually I just wanna further add on to
what ma told, uh, sir, we, you all the input,
because we want to know the context
of all the inputs at the timestamp, like how relevant it is.
See context, we anyway have,
which is coming from this context vector.
Yes, sir. Okay,
this context vector has the oral context.
Yes, sir. So based on that,
we are getting some probability kind of thing that Richard,
you told LA last time.
So the same thing, it'll be given to each and every input.
So that's why each and every input will have some
probability factor, like in this time step,
what should be the highest probability, right, sir?
So accordingly, we're giving all this inputs at that
Time. Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes. Okay.
Alright. So now let us focus on this alpha one,
one alpha one, two, alpha one, three,
how it is calculated, okay?
Now, uh, to, to understand how it is calculated,
okay, the alpha one, one, let, we have
to understand what is this number?
So this number we have understood as attention, attention,
uh, attention means what?
See if we will, uh, decode this word attention.
What we are trying to say is that when we have already,
so at the decoder timestamp, you have to see first of all,
and you have to see that what you have already generated.
So, so far you have already generated a man.
And this sno what you're seeing here, this Sno knows
that you have already generated me, okay?
So, so this attention, what I'm calculated here, C one,
it is somehow telling that, that I know
that I have already generated me
and now I want to generate the next word.
So whatever I have done so far, that is there in Sno,
that is there in the snot
and which word I have to generate next that I want
to know based on the current input map, okay?
Try to understand this one. So whatever I have already
generated, I know that is called Sno.
And now for, for the current input, may I want
to generate the next word that is J in this particular case.
So I want to have some alignment, assign some attention
between this s no,
because this is, this is very important, SNO,
because Sno knows that the word man is already generated.
So I don't have to again, stress on the word man. Okay?
S minus one doesn't know that, okay?
S minus one doesn't know, but s not knows that
because this is the updated vector now.
So this s not, so what we are trying to do is we are trying
to have some kind of alignment, alignment between the sno
alignment between the sno and the and and the H one.
You can say that, and that gives me alpha one, one
that gives me alpha one, one, okay,
I'm repeating once again.
So what we have to know is at each time a stamp
of the decode, which word in the encoder is important
or which set of words are important
or how much weight is important,
rather than saying important.
Now let us uh, uh, go with the word wait is
because anyway, every word is important,
but how much weight is we are giving to each of these word.
So at every time stamp of the decoder
how much weightage we are giving to the encoder words.
So, so far we have done with the SO,
which is coming from the last hidden timestamp here.
So we take up, we take the SO here
and we do the uh, uh, we do some calculation between s sno
and H one to get this alpha one one.
Similarly, we do the, we take Sno
and H two
and out of these we get alpha one, two, similarly Sno
and S3 together, give me the alpha one, three.
Now this is the first thing what we have to understand
and why, why,
because so far Esno knows that that
what word we have already generated.
And let us not focus because, uh, un
unless we don't have that understanding that
what is already generated, we can't give the focus,
we can't give the focus on a word more in the encoder
or less in the other words, in the encoder, right?
So that notion, we should have an S node or S minus one
or S one or S two, these context vector,
which is coming from the last hidden timestamp, they have
that understanding that, okay,
which word we have already generated, let us not, uh,
bother about that and focus on the next word.
Okay? Uh, so that is, that is the main important thing.
So now you can understand, right?
If we have to calculate this alpha one, one alpha one, two,
alpha one, three, we need some kind of alignment,
we need some kind of alignment between this sno here,
foresee when I'm talking Sno and H one
and similarly Sno and H two and Sno and H three.
And that will result in alpha one, one, alpha one, two,
alpha one, three, how to do that alignment that we'll see.
But this you have to understand, right?
Similarly at the next time stem, when we'll have
to calculate C two, this will move right, right toward here.
C two will come here, we'll have the alignment between
S one, okay?
Uh, because now we have this S one, S one
and H one, which will gimme alpha two, one, S one
and S two, which will gimme alpha two, two and S one
and S3 will gimme alpha two three,
and then I'll move this tight.
Then I'll calculate the alignment between S two
and H one, S two and S two and S two and S3.
And that is why the C one, C two C3, it changing every time
because my s no S one and S two is changing at upper
after every LSTM cells.
Okay? So this is what I have told here that alpha one, one,
alpha one, two alpha one three here
or here will be 2 1, 2, 2, 2, 3.
At third time time it'll be 3 1, 3, 2, 3, 3 at four time.
Seven be 4, 1, 4, 2, 4, 3, okay, likewise.
So it depends on, uh, which timestamp you are in.
The decoder, the first number representing that,
the second number is representing the timestamp in
theod timestamp.
So T represents the first number.
I represent the second number.
So T refers the decode timestamp,
I represent the encoded timestamp.
That's all here. It is written also.
So it is the alpha ti ITI you can understand.
Now it is an alignment, alignment with similarity,
kind of similarity score.
Similarity weight is, you can see that
between the decoded timestamp
and the encoder timestamp timestamps,
because in the encoder we have multiple timestamps,
then we have to consider all
of them decoder timestamp will remain same for
that particular timestamp.
Okay? So for example, alpha one comma one
or this one alpha one one,
we are generating the second word in the decoder,
we are generating the second word in theod.
That's what the statistical two one
and I is two one,
we're looking at the first word in the encoder.
I have told already. This alpha one one tells
how much importance should be given
to the encoder timestamp.
One, how much importance should be given to the encoder?
This is the encoder timestamp one, which is I,
while generating the decoder word at timestamp two.
So now I have to generate the decoder timestamp word,
which is J at the timestamp two.
But how much importance for that I should give
for the encoder timestamp one that is called alpha one one.
And similarly, you can imagine, right alpha one, two,
it'll say how much importance should be given
for the encoder timestamp two, which is the word M,
while generating the decoder at the second timestamp.
Okay? And one three will say,
how much importance should be given
for the encoder timestamp three,
which is going while generating the decoder
word at timestamp number.
So this is what, uh, uh,
uh, this is what, what it means.
This is what it means when we calculate alpha one,
one alpha one, two, and alpha one three.
Okay? Now, uh, still have not answered that question.
How do we calculate this alpha one,
one alpha one, two, alpha one, three.
But at least we are going slowly, we are going slowly in
that direction to understand that, okay, first of all,
we understood, okay, we need one, one vector here,
which will say, okay, which word is important?
That is C one is a vector. Now how to calculate the C one.
C one will be the alpha one, one
and two H one plus alpha one, two
and two H two alpha one, three and two H three.
Okay? Now the question is, what is the S alpha one,
one alpha one, two and alpha one, three.
And that is what we have understood now, okay,
so now the point is how to calculate this.
Now we'll see that one. How to calculate the sulfa tma.
I, so first of all, now we have understood
one thing that if we have to calculate the sulfa one,
one alpha, one, two, alpha one, three, we need a function,
mathematical function.
And that metric function will take two inputs for alpha one,
one, it'll take H one
and Sno for alpha one, two, it'll take S two and Sno.
And for alpha one three, it'll take S3 and Sno, right?
So in general, if you see the function for alpha, any DI,
it'll be function of i I represent the time
stamp of the encoder.
I represent the timestamp of the encoder,
and t represent the time stamp of the decoder.
So what it say, I need a function of hi,
I will be H 1, 2, 3
and s st minus one, St minus one s, st minus one
for the, so that its zero.
It is one that for the first time stamp, it'll be snot
for the second time stamp.
S one, third time stamp, S two fourth timestamp.
So one minus, because the snot S one,
S two is coming from the previous timestamp.
T this is the output of the previous lstm.
That's why T minus one. So I need these two inputs.
I will pass it through a particular function function.
We have to find what is that function.
And that function should give me this particular
scaler as an output.
I just need one scaler value, that's all.
But to get that scaler, I need these two inputs to pass,
and I have to find some alignment score between these two.
Correct? I guess this is fine.
So now this is how it'll look like at decoder timestamp one.
So this is decoder timestamp one, I guess here also,
there was some miss thing.
I I, when I run, it'll come correctly, don't worry.
So, uh, here, so this is a,
I I'm starting with the timestamp zero.
So I'm saying it's a timestamp one, okay?
So at timestamp one for alpha one, one, I need a function
of H one snot S two s, not H alpha one, two.
And for alpha one three, I need S3 snot.
These, these, these are the inputs.
These are the inputs for these function, okay?
Now, what is that function itself
that we have to understand?
So given the previous decoded estate, St minus one,
how important is encoded estate?
Hi for the predict for, for predicting the next quote
that we have already understood, right?
This is what is the meaning of this particular functions.
And this function will, whatever value it'll give in terms
of alpha power 1, 1, 1, 2, 1 3,
that value will represent exactly the same thing.
And that is what we want also.
And then we'll add all of them together by multiplying
with H one S two S3, once again, right?
So that is the final job,
but then we need this alignment score,
which measures the relevance between the encoder
and decoder estate, right?
Okay. Now here it is the actual calculation,
which is being done.
So I have to ti I have to somehow calculate the alpha one,
one, alpha one, two, alpha one, three,
and then I'll add all of them together, uh, with this H one,
H two S3 multiplication,
and then that's how we'll get the C one.
So the one way, there are multiple ways of doing that, one,
multiple ways of doing this one.
But what I am going to, uh,
show you is, um,
a neural network way of doing this one.
Because anyway, we have to calculate one, uh, uh,
one, uh, alignment.
C alpha two, one, or say alpha one, one alpha one, two,
alpha, one, three at this particular time stamp,
we need C one as an output.
So long, let us see this one. It's focus on this.
It's the same thing, what I have told you so far, so
that it'll not look complicated.
So I'm talking about the input at timestamp one,
the second word in the Dakota,
which I have to generate, okay?
Now, at this time, stamp, we have three inputs to be given.
Y one, Y one which is math, snot, which is coming from here,
and C one, which we have to calculate,
which we have to calculate.
Now, in order to calculate the C one, I need the alignment,
alignment between the sno, what I have already done so far,
and with Sno, with H one and S two and S3.
So there are three set of inputs, as I have shown you here
for alpha one, one, that will be H one Sno for alpha one,
two S, two Sno, alpha one, three S, three S one.
These three will be done, but
that is what I have written here.
Also. H one is not S two is not,
S3 is not these three set of inputs.
I need to calculate the alignment between them.
So what I am, uh, the way I'm doing here is
I am putting here one neural network, same neural network.
What is here is here also here also.
So way it starts shared between all of them,
although have shown three different thing,
but actually they're the same neural network
with the same set of weights.
So what happened first time, my input, H one
and S node, H one is also a vector.
Sno is also a vector, right?
So what I want is I want to feed this vector
to this particular neural network.
There are some neurons here showing here three,
but there can be many more also.
So there are three neurons, um, means some neurons here.
So somehow what I want is by feeding this H one
and as not to the neuron neurons, I want one score
as alpha one, one, how it'll come, how it'll come.
That, that, that again, I,
I'll tell you one more
architecture, then it'll be more clear.
But at the first level, let, let us understand.
I'm using here neural network, simple
and neural network is giving me one output.
Simple, okay?
This H one s not, this is not the actual representation
of neural network, which I'll show you later,
but just imagine that I have a neural network in between,
it takes two inputs, H one and Snu.
Both are, both are vectors.
So a vector here, vector here,
concatenating together, right?
Going as an input to this particular neural network
and gives me one output at alpha.
One, one. Similarly, S two snot goes to the neural network.
Give me one output at alpha, alpha one, two,
and here it is, alpha one three.
Okay? And then what we do, this alpha one, one alpha one,
two, alpha one three is further being multiplied
with H one, S two and S3.
You can see the alpha one one.
Once I get here, it gets again multiplied with H one, H one.
Anyway, we have from the encoder timestamps, right?
H one, S two, S3, so we can multiply them.
So it'll give me weighted weighted value of these H one,
S two and S3, because H one S two S3 is a vector.
Alpha one, one alpha, one, two, alpha one three is a scaler.
So when you multiply them, you get the weighted value
of this H one vector, H two vector, and H three vector.
Then you will add them, all of them.
So you here you can see that, right?
The add them, and then you get the output.
You get the output. Why I'm showing here three dimension,
because I have three, three, uh, uh,
um, means, uh,
because I'm giving the attention
to this H one, S two and S3.
So one value will be referring, uh,
uh, because it is a vector.
C one is a vector, right? Whatever you will get.
So the first value will refer the attention
for the first word in the encoder.
Second value will refer.
The second, uh, value will refer the attention
to the second word in the encoder.
And third value will refer the attention of the third value.
Simple. And that itself, now, you can see that this line,
C one, C one, all the way it travels here
and goes input to the here.
So unless we don't calculate the C one here,
this LSTM decoded, this particular time
of stem will wait, okay?
It has to, it has to wait,
and it has to do all these calculations.
What you're seeing in the website,
all these things will be done.
Get the C one and then feed it here to now get the S one
or generate the word J and give the, uh, output S one.
Okay? Now, this is what happened. Now, next time is time.
Now we have to calculate C two. Now you can see C two.
Now again, we have, it has to wait.
And this time you have to calculate the alignment
between S one, S two, S one and S one, S two, and SS one,
and S3 and S one,
because the context factor has changed here.
S one. So now you have to help with at, uh, alignment
between S one from for all here in the state of the encoder.
You'll pass it to the neural network.
You'll get alpha two one, alpha two, two alpha, two three,
multiplied with S one, S two, S3, add all of them together,
get C two, get C two,
and then feed it as in input to the, um, you can say that,
uh, 0 1 2, second time stamp of the Dakota.
And this process goes on. This process goes on.
Sir, one quick question. Yeah, please.
Uh, firstly, the dimension of, uh, H one
and S one as a vector has to be the same.
Is it?
Uh, uh, see, yes, it is same.
Yes, it is same in this, uh,
at least in this particular case, it is same.
And actually it is same only, right? Why? Why?
Because I will tell you, uh, remember from the L sst m,
we said that all the vectors, whatever we have,
their dimension has
to be same other than input other than, yes.
So th this, as you can understand, whatever context vector,
which is coming out of that, that itself is S one, S two,
S3 becoming S one.
So this vector context, vector dimension is same
as this H one, original S two.
So actually they're same, yes.
Answer. Second thing is
because now alpha is a scaler, which is an output
of a neural network, some activation function,
which gives the output as a scaler we'll have to use.
Uh, no, there, there is a little mystery.
I'll just show you the next slide, okay, sir?
Yeah, thank you. Yeah.
But we do use the activation function,
but the, uh, I'll show you the actual architecture.
Yeah.
Okay. So now, uh,
before I'll show you those, uh, the actual things, uh,
let us see if we do this one.
That what change has happened.
So this is the change which is given in the one
of the paper, uh, called, uh,
I will just write attention.
So this is the, in the 2014 itself,
this paper has also come, okay?
And they have used the sequence
to sequence architecture on top of that,
they have applied their attention,
and this is what they have.
Uh, uh, in fact, they have, uh, they have used the,
this kind of architecture, the, uh, LSTM
or RN architecture.
You can buy an architecture.
And on top, top, top of that,
they have applied the attention, not on the sequence
to sequence, but this is what they said, okay?
This is what they have said that,
uh, you can see that, right?
So if, if earlier what was happening just
because, uh, there was no attention, uh, then
after 20 words, the, this was the, this was the trend.
That model performance was dropping,
model performance was dropping, right?
But if you introduce the sequence to sequence, uh,
I'm sorry, attention on this, uh,
RNN architecture, then what will happen?
This line, what this curve, what you're seeing on the top,
that what will happen, it'll still, it'll,
it'll at least not drop.
It'll be even increasing or at the same stage at least.
So that is what was shown even
after the, uh, sentence length is 20.
Okay? If it is 30, 40, 50, 60, the curve is not dropping.
But the other curves, which was dropping
and where the attention was not used,
so this was one breakthrough paper, which came at that time.
And, uh, yeah, this is the same thing.
So you can see that the blue score, uh, which,
which we usually, we calculate in the case of, uh,
machine translations as well.
This is one of the accuracy measure.
You can see that per, uh, metric.
And, uh, it is not dropping. This score is not dropping.
And if you see the attention, the way it was calculated,
so they have done mainly for English to French, okay?
And, uh, you can see, right?
So for a particular word in English,
which word in the French is important,
that attention is being captured.
So black means zero means no attention,
and one white, white means one means the full attention.
And anything in between will have the,
that much weightage of the tension, okay?
That is what it is. So you can see that for the word, uh,
this maybe, uh, this,
this particular word French is important.
Uh, but I want you to concentrate here somewhere
where you can see that, right?
For the word, ma'am, maybe
there are multiple words which are important in
the, uh, encoder.
In the encoder, right?
So obviously all of all of them are not
with the same weight is,
but it doesn't, it, it is never intended
to focus only on one word.
It is always intended
to focus on the entire words in the encoder.
So if support these many words we have in the encoder,
everything we have to focus, but waiters will be different.
Some words will have more say.
Some words will have very little say.
Some, some words will have no say at all in, in order
to do the conversion or translation.
But let us have, calculate the tension with the entire,
and that is what it's shown here.
That's why you can see that some variation,
obviously this part and this part is almost not here.
You can see some shades of, uh, black, right?
Mean that is not exactly zero, maybe 0.0002
or something, right?
Or something, something like it is captured.
So this is what has happened in the part, no attention.
And now I'm showing you the actual, uh, paper, uh, so far,
whatever I've shown you, it is like, just
to build up the idea that in order to get that attention
or getting that C one C two attention vector,
I am using the, uh, what is that neural network.
But then how does neural network look like?
That is what is shown here now in this particular figure.
So this figure, now, we are going to see how
that neural networks looks like,
and then how this whole architecture works.
So basically, now you can see that I have the same encoder
where I'm feeding the word.
I am going, I got the context vector.
Now, I'm not showing you only the context vector.
This H three, which is coming from here,
giving me the context vector of the entire encoder.
Of the entire encoder. And that goes here. This, this blue.
Okay? So the same context vector goes here as an input,
as S minus one, same thing.
It is, okay?
So S3 here and S minus one here, both are the same thing.
First of all, let us understand that. Okay?
But I have broken that to represent you. Okay?
How does this, uh, attention calculation happen?
So these are the three step process in order
to calculate the ct.
CT can be, uh, starting with CO, then C one, then C two, C3,
and C four, four times it'll be calculated, uh,
0, 1, 2, 3, and four.
So five times it'll be calculated, starting
with zero up going up to four.
Now, how does it, how do we calculate, first of all,
we require this E one one, E one, two, E one, three.
Okay, so what is this? E one one, E one two, E one, three.
It is the score scaler value to the scaler value,
or it is the actual alignment value, which say, okay,
when I have to calculate the C one, I need
to calculate the alignment between the SNO
and H one, then Sno and H two, and then Sno
and H three that we have already seen, right?
So alignment between SNO and H one will be E one one Sno,
and S two will be E one two Sno, and S3 will be E one three.
Now we have these as scaler alignment,
and together we will, it'll become the vector.
So what is happening basically, is that E one one?
How do we calculate that? What the question earlier also.
So we use one neural network in between,
and this neural network takes two inputs.
First, first input is the edge, edge, uh,
uh, hj.
So J is nothing,
but, uh, here it is like H one,
S two, S3, okay?
H one, H two, H three. Okay?
So, uh, it'll be like, uh, first time it'll be H one,
then S two and S3.
And now you can see here, s uh, it, it, uh, it is,
uh, SI minus one.
It should have been T minus one.
Here it is written T minus one,
but, uh, here it is, I minus, that's the,
there is some notational change, which I have missed.
Some typo error. So here it is like st minus one
ST minus one will be snot in this case.
So one S node, next time it'll be S two s.
No, next time it'll be S3 S node.
And now you see that there is a neural network in between.
And there is this neural network
is a two layered neural network, two layered neural network.
We have one hidden layer here and one output layer here.
Okay? Two layer. Two layer, it is,
so there is one hidden layer, one output layer,
and whatever is the dimension of hj
and SI minus one, we have concatenated them together,
they will go as an input together
to this particular neural network.
And whatever is the neural network output here will go
and connect it with one neuron here.
So what will happen for each h, uh, uh, edge
and SP, okay?
Of input, you will get one alignment score, E one one.
So as node as no will give you E one, one HNO
S one will give you E one two,
and HNO s uh, uh, sorry, H uh,
HH two Sno will give you E one, two and H three.
Sno will give you E one three. Okay?
Now, how it is done, that is what is written here.
So you see that, as I said,
it is a two layered neural network.
In the first layer, what happens?
So obviously we have some weights in between, which will be,
which we, we have to train.
So, uh, at this particular layer, what happened,
we do the weighted PL bias, followed by activation function,
and the activation function, which they use.
Then the tension,
and they use the okay that use the 10 10 H
activation function.
So 10 H is an activation function, as you can see
that there is a weight ws, which is connected
with ST minus one.
This is T, right? So ST minus one,
and there is a weight which is connected with hj,
so WH into hj.
And we have a bias also, which is coming
with all these neurons here.
Simple. This is this, we do for any neural network,
it's a fully connected network, right?
And then whatever output we get, okay,
that whatever output we get, uh, that, uh,
okay, that whatever, whatever output we are getting, that,
that we are, uh, uh, uh, some, somehow we have to
multiply it because it is a, um, um, uh,
because this, this et comma J et comma j, what
what you are going to get is, is a, uh,
this EEE one, one, E one two, E one, three.
It is, it is a scaler value.
How it'll be a scaler
because you're using a single neuron
here, single neuron here.
So here you're using the 10 x activation function here.
You'll not use any activation function.
It is a linear activation function.
Whatever it'll calculate, it'll give you the E one one,
E one, two, E one, three.
So resultant of this particular part,
and followed by this multiplied by this V, okay?
V is a vector here, V, which is, which is weight.
Which is weight. So V you will multiply,
what you will get will be one scaler.
What you will get as VE one, one E one, two, E one,
three, okay?
So two set of weights are being used that you have
to remember W and V.
And that is what is shown here also. Okay?
So once we get the E one one, E one, two, E one, three,
because we have
to normalize them in the range of zero to one.
Softex is the good activation.
Softex is a good normalization function. Here, it's okay.
So now it'll take all these three value using this
particular formula, it'll normalize.
Now you have the priority distribution in terms
of alpha one, one, alpha one, two,
and alpha one, three, okay?
And then what you will do, you will simply, um,
calculate the ci, how will you calculate the CI
or ct ct You will calculate by,
you will multiply this alpha one,
one alpha one 12 alpha one three, along with the hj.
That is H one, S two, S3, okay?
And then you add all of them together.
That's why there is just submission.
That's why there is just submission, right?
And that's how you get a vector here, which you are going
to feed to this l sst.
So sir, here will be three neuro network
for each E one one, E one 12,
No, let see, neural network is same.
Only thing is three inputs.
Okay, sir? Yeah.
First time HNO and, uh, sorry, huh? HH one and snot.
It's like RO wise input, you're feeding.
There are three inputs in your data set.
Yes, there is lot.
Okay, so one more question I was trying to ask earlier,
also, how it'll maintain the sequence.
For example, I'm taking your, I am going,
but in Hindi translation going is coming
and going, is coming earlier, actually, jar.
Mm-hmm. So that thing, how it is maintaining,
That's why we are finding the alignment.
This E one one, E one two, E one three, along
with these wave in between is trying to learn the,
see anyway, we are doing the supervised learning
where we have the labels there in our data set.
So somehow with these waves, we are trying
to learn the same thing that, okay,
now this word should be J although it is coming later or
before in the encoder here, it has to come as J.
So that is what, and suppose it does the mistakes,
obviously at the training time, it'll do the mistake, okay?
Which is not shown here.
But then that is what the, uh, model will understand, okay?
What is the laws and update those, uh, all those parameters,
and again, feed this, uh, next, next, uh, input.
And by doing it multiple times, it'll learn that. Yeah.
Yes, thank you. Okay,
Sir? Uh,
I have some trouble understanding this, uh, VT
in the first step, VT multiplied
by the activation function. It,
It just to transpose.
So what is happening is, uh, this is a vector.
So this is a neural network hidden layer,
and I am treating the output of this hidden layer,
neural hidden layer.
Output is a vector. Now, this vector has to be multiplied
with the vector here, which is a v, V is a vector, right?
We are set of weights between this layer and this layer.
So one of them has to transpose. That's why we transpose.
Okay? Okay, got it.
Okay. That's all. Nothing else. So vector and vector.
So vector and vector is being, uh, multiplied, that's all.
So we get, what we get here is in, uh, scaler.
Understood, sir? Yeah. Okay. Okay.
So, uh, yes, that's all. This is, what is the word?
Not attention. The first kind
of attention which was proposed first of its kind, then
after this, multiple types
of attention mechanism, which was proposed.
And one of the version, uh, you will see,
and very famous, is self attention in the transformer
architecture, which we'll talk in the next course.
But you see from where this attention has emerged
and why it has emerged,
what was the purpose initially, right?
And, uh, what, what exactly.
So if you see here, uh, what, what there are,
what we are doing, first of all,
we are calculating the alignment between the sequence,
what we have here in the decoder,
and each word in the encoder, get that attention.
That is E one one or alpha one,
one alpha one, two, alpha one, three.
And then again, multiply it with the H one, S two,
S two in order to give them the weighted, in order
to give them the weighted
and then add them together to get, get the seat.
This is what we do in the case of pardon, no attention.
Okay? Now, uh, I'll explain you one more kind of attention,
one more kind of attention, which was proposed later.
That is called luon attention, L-U-O-N-G. Okay?
Luong attention paper. I mean, lu, why?
We, because the author name is Luon. Okay?
So effective approach to attention based neural, uh,
machine translation.
So what they said that so far, uh, what this,
uh, this, this is doing is,
um, tension.
Uh, Barna is a, the author name.
So bar tension is doing is in order
to give this alignment score, E one one, E one two, E one,
three, it is using the neural network in between anyway,
this LSTM has the neural network in encoder
as well as in the decoder.
And then in order to calculate the attention score, also,
we are calculating the,
we are having the neural network again, there also,
we have the set, uh, some weights in the form of W
and some weight in the form of V.
So it is becoming so complex, it is becoming so complex.
And, but the ultimate idea is only to calculate the,
uh, what is that alignment?
Similarity between this vector, SNO here
and the vector, which H one Sno here and S two Sno and S3.
Then why to have this neural network.
So he said that, can't we make it little, uh, simpler?
So instead of keeping the neural network in between,
I will just do the dot product
dot product of the two vector.
Again, it'll gimme the same thing.
It'll gimme the scaler, right?
So HJ means H one, S two, or S3,
or here I'm saying si.
It should have been st. Sorry, it should have been st. Okay?
So, um, uh, so here, so
what I'm doing is this is also a vector.
This is also a vector, and we have already talked about they
are of the same dimension.
So if they're of the same dimension,
and we have to calculate the alignment
or similarity between these two
dot product is the best way, okay?
And we don't don't have to train any of these weights.
W and V, W
and V, we don't have to train any of these, right?
So it'll make the overall process a little bit simpler.
Rest, everything is same.
Once we have this E one, one, E one, two, E one,
three in place, then we can calculate alpha one, one,
alpha one, 12 alpha one, three,
and then we can just, uh,
multiply these individual weightage with the H one S two S3,
and add them together to get this C one.
The, the attention. Okay? The attention.
So getting the attention value, um, how you are getting
that attention vector.
That is what is different in luang attention.
And the au attention,
the au attention use the neural network in between
to get the C one, right?
But the luang attention, they say that, okay,
I'll use the dot product.
The dot product is a multiplication, uh, operation.
So Luang is multiplicative attention.
And, uh, uh, here a bar.
No, it isn't, uh, EA additive attention there.
We, we say it is a additive attention
because, uh, anyway, neural network,
we are calculating here, we are only doing the addition
of all of them, which we do here also.
I don't know why it just check that,
why it is called a multiplication
and, uh, multiplicative and additive.
But you understand the process, right?
I am focusing more on this.
How do we calculate this alignment score.
Alignment score is just a number, scaler number,
which gives the alignment between the two vector.
So bar now, do, does, is using the neural network
and Luang does it using the top product.
That's all. Now, there is one more difference,
and now you must have observed by it, uh, by, by now that,
okay, once you get this attention, the way it is being fed
to the burden or attention is it is acting like another
input to this lstm.
So this LSTM has anyway, input Y one and A snot.
Now also, it'll have one more input C one, okay?
This is how this attention vector goes, as an input
to the LS tm, but the way, uh,
long did it was a little different.
What he did, uh, once it get the C one,
it did not give the input to this lstm.
It did not give the input to this lium what it said. Okay?
Let the, uh, LSTM generate whatever it has
to generate S one, okay?
S one here based on the current word, ma,
and last vector snot.
But once it'll give the SSS one as an output, okay?
Which is vector. S one is vector.
All these are vectors, right? S one.
Then I'll take this S one,
and out of this S one, out of this S one,
this is attention vector C one.
I will concatenate them
and I'll pass them to the neural network here, okay?
I will pass them to the neural network here.
So, uh, it is, it is little bit different the way this
attention vector is fed.
Okay? So attention vector in the burden,
attention is straightforward as an input
in the long attention.
It is little complicated.
Now, the C one is going as an input S one
and C one gets concatenated.
Like here, like here, sorry, like here, h, h
and S is being concatenated, going
to the neural network right here.
Similarly. Now you can imagine S one
and C one is being concatenated going
to the needle network, okay?
Again, uh,
Is that concatenation or addition?
Uh, I think you said added two, right?
It's like H shown and S one are added. Mm, concatenated
No, but it is concatenated actually.
So that's why I, I show here.
You, you see this, the last, uh, uh, step number four,
once we get the ct, like, like C one, C two, C3,
whatever you have to get No,
No, no, I'm saying the previous case, right?
Other one, yeah. Here it's concatenation addition
here, this one
I just J and C one. Yeah.
Uh, so basically what happened,
I'm just paying the additive
or multiplicative based on the last
operation, what I'm performing.
So last operation, I,
what I performed is an additive operation here, right?
And that itself gave me the C one
and C one we fed as an input to this recorder.
So based on that, I said additive, but last operation
after the C one is not as it is here, we do some
multiplication in the form of neural network.
Okay? Okay. So we see it
as a multiplicative attention, that's all.
Okay? So, uh, you see this,
what we are doing is this S one and C one.
So CT and sst, both, they are being concatenated, multiplied
with the weight, pass it through the activation function,
10 edge and get, give this st.
So S one is not the output, final output here from S one,
you'll get one more vector as an output.
That is called S one dash or, uh, uh, uh, til, okay?
And that will be the final output, which, which will say
that, what is the next word, which is going
to be predicted at this particular time of step.
So now this is the, this is the little change
in the longer attention and the burden or attention.
Okay? So, uh, yeah, only two, two places.
You have to ob ob observe the change the way the attention
itself is being calculated here,
it is calculated using the neural network.
Here it is calculated using the DO product, the main,
main difference in calculating the attention.
Now, how that attention is fed to the decoder.
So in the case of attention, it is fed to the decoder
as an input to the LT,
but in the de in the long attention,
it is not fed to the L SST M.
Okay? Whatever L SST M output we are getting,
and whatever is the attention, they are again, concatenated.
Pass it to one more head layer.
One more you can say that the fully corrected layer
where the 10 H is an activation function
and get the output, that final output will decide
what is the, what is the next word,
which we are going to put it here.
So in that way, it is slightly different from the,
okay, so yeah, let, let me,
let me know if you have any query here.
First of all, sir, when
We say concatenation, what does it mean?
Uh, concatenation, uh, simply mean that suppose CT
has, has four value vector, right?
And ST is for, uh, for value.
Now, together there will be
eight dimensional vector together.
There'll be, so just, I have just concatenated them.
There, there is no addition, just concatenated them.
So now the vector, what I, I will have
after the conation will be of eight dimension.
That is the meaning of it. Okay, sir? Yeah,
Sir, which one performs the best?
Uh, which one perform best? I don't know.
I, I have not done the, actually they have,
I don't know whether they have compared it or not.
I just see the paper, uh,
but I believe neural network is in the long,
we have neural network here,
and in the, we have neural network here,
but in both the cases, we have the neural network.
So I don't see any much, any, any,
any problem would be there in, in getting the output, uh,
because anyway, it's, everything is being weighed.
So we are loss calculation back propagation is happening.
So I, I don't have answer as of now.
We have to check, we have to experiment and check. Yeah,
Understood.
Experimented, yeah.
Uh, In this, uh, no attention and long attention, sir.
Mm-hmm. So, you know, the difference is
that when we calculate this alignment score,
so there we use this, uh, tan function,
and then we use the weights, whereas in the luang,
we don't directly do a DOT product.
Mm-hmm. So, but we use any activation function
to learn the non-line the data.
And if you see the entire attention, what I inferred is
that this alignment score is a very critical parameter,
which keeps changing the values of alpha when thereafter
accordingly, the context structure also
changes every time step.
So if we remove this, uh, activation function
and then directly go for a DOT product, so are we not, uh,
limiting ourselves to learn the complexity
or the complex patterns?
Because, uh, in that, uh, long, uh, the,
the same activation function, we just do a dot product.
And again, he does the same thing afterwards going, uh,
the output of the lium.
So if you see that weight parameters low,
only one weight getting, uh, limited, that is s uh,
and the w only that thing getting normed off,
even the parameter basic, you see that, uh, even, uh,
this ang and the banu,
there is slight radiation in the trainable parameters.
But when, what I understand now, what I infer is
that when we come to the performance processor, I feel
that since the tanish function introduced in the alignment
score stage itself, which plays a critical role in further
calculation of the alpha,
and then thereafter the context factor, so that, uh,
should be the more, uh, uh, uh, valid, uh,
way of getting an attention.
They're going for a long attention kind of thing.
Maybe, I mean, uh, your,
your argument may might be correct, but, uh,
unless we don't do the experiment, may not be have,
but maybe your argument seems to be correct here that okay,
you're trying to capture the non-line non-linearity while
calculating the attention itself.
Yes, sir. Which the low attention doesn't do,
and it does it later part of the time later
after calculating the, so, but here it is doing something,
but let us see that.
Let us, but you have understood the fact, right?
And now, yes, sir, this experiment,
maybe it'll be more clear.
That is why. Yes, sir. Yeah.
So even here, also,
if you use this activation function also since Tanach,
we have the values, we are limiting from
minus one to plus one, sir.
Mm-hmm. So accordingly, we can able to even avoid
that vanishing gradient problem so
that the values cannot further go.
Mm-hmm. So that kind of, uh,
problem can be addressed if you use this tanach at the
calculation of alignment score.
So rather than leaving it open
and just giving a doubt product kind of thing,
Maybe, but as I said, I have not done the experiment.
I don't have much, but argument wise,
it's looking fair to me as of now.
Yeah. Yeah. Good.
But the good thing is understanding the attention
with the sequence to sequence modeling is,
is a tricky little bit complicated,
but I believe you people are able to understand that that is
what is more important here.
Now, we'll see that in the next class sequence
to sequence hands on whatever I have shared
with the same code.
Next time, I'll try to add some of these attention layer in
between, and if I'll, I'll see
that in the pipes if I have this long attention
and barau tension separately,
More, Uh, anything.
Uh, no, sir. Sorry, sir.
Okay. Okay. No problem. So we'll see that one.
We will try to do those experimental. We'll see that. Yeah.
Okay. So finally, uh, this is the final slide
for today maybe where, uh, uh, again,
every approach which is given has some limitation, right?
So obviously these attention approach was given.
But one thing, what you can understand with this whole, uh,
processes, the, the way we are making it complicated,
the way we are mocking,
making the entire network complicated in the sense
that first of all, encoder has
to go times stamp wise manner.
Suppose there are thousand times stamp,
thousand timestamp has to be performed at the encoder
itself, then it'll go to the recorder.
And here also support.
There are thousand timestamp, thousand timestamp has
to be calculated one by one.
That itself is very, very, very, uh, uh, slow process on top
of that for every, uh, timestamp.
Now, we started calculating the attention, right?
And the attention calculation itself is very,
very complicated job
because you have to calculate either dot product,
then pass it to the, uh, neural network,
or first you have to pass it to the noodle network
and calculate the dot product
and feed it as an input to the LS tm.
So the whole process has become so complex.
Whole process has become so complex.
It might be working, but it is very slow.
That is first thing. So com computational
complexity is very high.
And if you know, most, uh, some of you have, uh,
are from computer science in background,
you must have learned about this complexity,
time complexity and all.
So clearly, it is showing that if encoder length is
and decoder length is, um, and suppose,
and as you call to m right?
Then the complexity will be order
of n squared minimum, okay?
Minimum in order to come.
Because for every deco, uh, decoder you are going
through every encoder time stamp.
So, and in two n this is N square, okay?
It can be more than that also. It can be more than that.
Also, uh, if you don't do the padding and all
but order of n squared,
you can just understand which is too high.
So training time is too high.
Each decor step waits for the previous step.
LSTM is inherently sequential,
no parallelization across timestamps.
So between 2015
and 17, I think 2015, this strong attention has given.
So there are different kind of attention mechanism was given
to simplify this process.
Various optimized attention mechanism, process, for example,
something called as local attention, hierarchical attention,
and many other kind of attention, right?
Uh, so, but then, uh, people try
to simplify this part, okay?
How to calculate the attention, okay?
How to sim, uh, simplify the calculation of this attention.
But they, the, the bottleneck, bottleneck was
that every time stamp
of the recorder required the attention.
And to calculate that we have to do whatever way we,
it may be little complicated or little bit simple,
but this process has
to be calculated at each time a stamp of the Dakota.
So this was the bottleneck.
Later people realized that,
but the real issue was not the attention and
however you are calculating the attention or simplifying
or complexing it, but the core bottleneck was the
LS TM itself, okay?
Because that has to happen for every time stamp manner.
And that's why in 2017 when the transformer architecture
came, they removed the LSTM itself
because the bottleneck was, uh, LSTM, not the attention.
So they retained the attention concept in the architecture,
remove the L lstm, they said that L LSTM is the bottleneck,
let's process everything in parallel, and it became so fast.
So that's why, uh, the, the self attention, uh, uh, was
so popular, which we'll see in the next course in detail.
Okay? So I'll stop here today.
If you have any other queries,
you can ask me the next class.
We are now left with two classes.
See, Monday, I'll be traveling.
I will, I will also try to connect.
Uh, I, I hope that, uh,
wherever I'll be the internet connection, I'll get to.
Good. So Monday, what I'm planning is
that I'll show you the demo for this one, the attention,
we will repeat everything, same machine translation,
what we did in the previous class,
but on top of that, we'll add that attention.
So we'll have quick revision of that code, first of all,
and we'll also see the attention integration.
Uh, suppose there will be some problem then I, uh,
we'll directly meet on Saturday or Sunday.
Okay? Uh, we don't have to cover any new topic topic-wise.
We have completed everything. We have two classes left.
If I get one class, also, I will show you the demo.
And I guess that is all for this particular course.
If I will have the two classes that is, that is, uh,
more than sufficient,
I guess the second class when we'll have on the Saturday
or maybe Sunday, I'll inform you that, uh, uh, uh,
we'll have the maybe some question related query,
query related, so we can do that course.
Yeah.
One question, sir, please. Excuse me, sir.
Sir, this, uh, head start is that product, why can't we go
for a cross product, sir?
Why is it that we need to go for, because
Dot product, dot product give you a
scaler as an output, right?
So yes, sir. The scaler value, the,
because we have to give the weightage weightage for each
of these vectors.
H one, H two, and S3. Hmm.
Now, if we give vector, multiply with the vector,
so you can go with the cross product also,
but then that will not serve my purpose.
Attention is like alignment
between the two sequence, two sequence alignment.
When it comes as a scaler, then it'll make some sense,
because anyway, we have the soft max.
We are getting the, that two sequence,
and I say, okay, these two are similar by 50% or 80%.
It makes sense, right? Instead of say 50%, 80%,
I'll say 0.5, 0.8, 0.9, what?
You'll understand what is alignment
you'll not understand. No, sir.
Yes, sir. But my question is, with vector,
we can feed in more information rather than scaler.
That is my, uh,
I understand your point, what you said, you understand,
but then I have to give the waites to each of these vector.
With the vector, uh, uh, uh, with the scaler,
I can give the, because scaler acts like a weight, okay?
Which I have to give E one one, E one, two, E one, three,
it acts like a weight.
So then I can multiply it with the H one, S two, S3,
which will act like how much weight is I'm giving
to this H one, S two, and S3.
So that's why I'm using this one, right?
As a, uh, uh, as a, as a dot product, uh, dot product.
Because I think you, if you know, the dot product,
dot product is meant for giving you the similarity
between the two vectors, cross product is not meant
for giving the similarity.
Yes. Okay? Yeah,
Sir. Okay,
sir, I already consent.
Yes, Sir?
Uh, I have a very quick request, uh, to make, sir.
So, uh, currently I have come to Delhi on an official duty,
so I may not be able to attend, uh,
my classes for the next week.
So I need, I request some relaxation with, uh, the summary,
submission on other things.
Okay? We'll see that. Yeah.
Uh, uh, I need to, uh, have, uh,
a quick five minute presentation with everyone is
I will see that No problem.
No, uh, no. In this class.
I'll, I'll just, uh, present my screen
for a few minutes now, two or three minutes. Yes.
Do you have any doubt? Uh, not, not exactly doubt,
but uh, I have something to share with all of you.
No. What is, what is that?
Yeah. Uh, uh, I think everyone would've known of this, uh,
a expo thing that is happening in Delhi.
Oh, you can do that later. Maybe.
Let us, uh, let me, uh, stop.
Uh, anyway, I have stopped now. Any, anyone else? Okay.
You have any query?
Uh, just like, uh, last time, uh, uh,
you gave a sample question paper, right, sir?
Similarly, can, can you give for this also?
Oh, I, uh, okay. Sam, you
Gave one, uh, for our, uh, previous, uh, just one,
you gave a set of 20 questions you had given
Mm-hmm.
Which was quite useful to understand how the,
Okay. Uh, maybe,
uh, Vimal, can we do
that vimal added?
Are you there
any I'll just check.
I'll just check with them. Sure, sir.
Yeah, sir, in the same style as you are planning, uh,
miss the question paper you're asking.
Yes, sir. Yeah, so I mean,
I think we have given the format already.
I think you already have that right?
For the sample question.
Paper will try to give no problem, which is the form.
I don't know. I'll ask my classmates.
I don't know the format. Yeah, it is there.
I guess we have already shared what will be the format Okay.
Question marks and all, so that we have already shared.
Okay, sir. I think for all courses,
that format is available somewhere, I guess in the Yes, sir.
Yes. Yeah, it's a
Sir. Yeah. Yeah.
Also, Also given
In the group also, I have shared that in the group.
Okay. Okay. Take,
Thank you, sir.
Yeah, good, sir. Thank you.
Now, thank you, sir. Who was present.
Now others can be those who want stay, you can stay.
Yeah. So wanted to share something actually.
Yeah, A AI conference is happening there in Delhi,
and it's a big one, so maybe some updates.
It'll be good. The maybe if you are available at this. Yeah,
Yeah, yeah.
I just order to, uh, actually what I'm going,
so I'll just share, I'm just sharing my screen,
so I think my screen is visible.
Yeah, Yeah. So I, uh, I'm sorry to
share this particular invitation, this layer,
but, uh, this is our particular stall, which we are, uh,
but actually exhibiting our projects in the apo.
Oh. So,
And what is the date?
16 to 20 all the day. You would be
There from 16 to 20.
I, uh, I'll be there for all the five days, along
with a few offices.
Who, who will be in the rotation shift
Then? I'll meet you.
19 and 20. I'm coming.
Yeah, definitely. So definitely. Sure.
I, myself and directors are both, are coming. We'll, yeah,
It would be an honor to meet you at the time.
Definitely. Sure.
So, uh, this is a quick, uh, preface of the project that we,
that we'll be presenting at the expo.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, good, good, good. Then. Anyway, we will meet others.
Also, if you can make it, I, uh, all of you must be knowing
that India is making, uh,
a very biggest step in this AI
with this summit. Okay, let us see.
So this is, this is the current, uh, portfolio,
uh, from our unit.
So out of which, uh, from computer vision, uh, SmartShip,
operations, worship funder, this gang management system.
And these are the projects that we currently have in the,
out of which we'll be presenting, uh, the third day.
And, uh, worship finder, worship finder, it just, uh,
it just developed, uh, with, uh, collaboration
with, uh, b bang.
And, uh, this third day is my project,
which I have worked on,
and I have developed, it'll be going into date next,
go from, uh, next week.
So other than that, uh, in the general portfolio, we have,
uh, qb MS, uh, content generator and other tools.
Uh, and this is exclusively for all the na, uh,
Navy enable requirements.
Mm-hmm. So this particular tool, which is, which is, uh, uh,
pretrained, uh, I mean, uh, it is
as a particular generative issue,
which is trained upon 50,000 NA documents, rules
and regulations and other laws.
Okay? So other than that, uh, this, uh,
the language translation projects, which we have are six
out of these projects.
So ION is our known, uh, in-house developed project.
Sand was a in-house develop project,
inhouse develop project NIP
is the inhouse developed project.
And, uh, third is the in-house developed project.
So, and other, other than this, uh, the,
these other projects were outsourced to
them, contractual partners.
Mm-hmm. So, uh, these are the quick,
uh, overview of the projects.
So this SmartShip operations are dedicated for, uh,
dedicated, uh, application for, uh, ships, the,
which are sailing in the Indian water.
So this can easily track
and identify the distant ships, which are, uh,
present in the, which are sail in the same water.
So, uh, next is the worship finder.
So this is dedicated to find out, uh, uh, which are,
which are the class of worship that is being in the field
of, of the cameras, of our, uh,
particular Indian naval ships.
So, uh, this is a gang management system.
It is from a system which is going to be installed
with the chips to identify personnels, uh,
authorized personnels who are, uh, into, uh, who are, uh,
who used to like, who are on the dock,
and, uh, who often, uh, more here and there.
And, uh, third, this is the third I, which is my project,
and it is, uh, specifically A-C-C-T-V surveillance project.
So, uh, it's a built on live rt, SP camera schemes.
So the processing will be done for
and, uh, person detection, uh, person recognition
and homo graphic, uh, facial recognition, facial mapping.
And, uh, each
and every data is shared, uh, saved in the database
for the post processing, uh, things.
So in the post processing, we have also added, uh, chat bot
and another, uh, uh, generative tools so that, uh,
whatever data is, uh, getting, uh, detect, uh,
whatever the detections and recognitions are getting stored,
uh, the user can later have a proper, uh, report
and a graphical kind of, uh, interface
or graphical kind of realization report.
So this is my project.
So, uh, the next, this is, uh, an outsourced project.
It is, uh, zone based, uh, person tracking.
So, uh, this is, uh,
advanced face recognition app application, which is only
for the tablets, which is, uh, limited for tablets.
So, uh, usually the soldiers,
so the level offices carry tablets with themselves.
So it is, uh, uh, in installed with them.
And, uh, it, uh, it is used to recognize, uh, personals.
So this particular project Sander,
it is the biggest project which we have in the unit.
And, uh, it comprises of entire intelligence suite, uh,
which we call, uh, it comprises of all the gpt.
And each and every GPT is particularly for a single, uh,
you, uh, particular, particular for single purpose.
So, uh, for the rules
and regulations, we have a separate GPT for fast generation,
we have spread GPT,
and all these are, uh, pretrained on, uh, naval documents,
which is confidential.
So, uh, there are particular, uh, format in, uh,
in the na in the Navy to send the fax and other documents.
So these, uh, these formats are preferred as to the model.
And, uh, the user is required only to give the context
and, uh, generate the facts and everything.
So it reduces the manual, uh, manual drafting time.
So, uhnot, uh, this is a meeting management system, which,
uh, effectively, uh, uh,
whenever we are uploading an audio of,
uh, an entire meeting.
So, uh, this, this particular, uh, software does is that it,
uh, provides a per ization per percent
to percent transcription.
So it also provides translation summary
of the entire meeting and minutes of, uh, meeting.
So minutes of meeting compress action points
done by each and every speaker.
So, uh, it, it is a meeting revolutionary application.
Uh, next comes, uh, uh, the QBMS.
It is, uh, based for, uh, smart examinations, uh,
for the people in the academies.
So other than that, this ca driven gen, uh,
content generator, it is an online application where, uh,
we wrapping goes on every day to fix the latest news
and other latest updates that is going on in the world,
and it just, uh, throws up in the,
uh, in the display screen.
Other than that, we can also have,
we also have a chat bot within this,
so user can ask particular question about, uh,
any update that we have got.
And, uh, there will be a detailed explanation of
detailed expression related to, to that particular update.
So, uh, these are,
these are few other projects which we have outsourced.
And, uh, so,
and this one projection is the in-house development project.
So this is basically an instructor student
where we have, uh, students, international students, uh,
with various linguistic backgrounds
in the Naval Training Academy.
So in this, all this application does will work, uh,
instructor will be teaching, uh, in the English language,
and the students can, uh, have their, uh,
learnings in their, uh, own native language.
It, it does live transcription translation
and, uh, text speech conversion to their own language.
So it also has a feature of audio books
where the instructor uploads, uh, textbook notes
and other pdf f things,
and the entire document will be converted into an audio of,
uh, the choice of the student.
And the student can hear the audio,
and, uh, it makes it easy for him to look.
So this was a quick audio of the pro projects
that we have been doing for Indian Union.
So, uh, that's all.
I just wanted to give an audio about
the project that we have done.
So, uh, this is a formal invitation for people
who are, are available.
Please visit us and, uh, please have an interaction
with this so that we can, is
One thing, uh, if, if possible, can, I mean, eh,
the presentation you have shared is in public domain.
I mean, if it is possible, can you share with us the link?
Yeah, yeah. The browser is public.
Uh, like we have, uh, been printing the browsers, uh,
nearly a thousand credit browsers.
We have been prepared so that we, we weekly sharing, uh,
to every delegate who is visiting us hundred
for eight per day.
I, I'm saying for us, for us,
Yeah. But no issues. I,
I have the permission to share it
with my college group, so I'll be sharing it in the group.
Yeah, sure, Sure. Thank you. So, I,
I'll also be sharing this invitation in the group so that,
uh, people who are nearby daily, please make your time.
I, I'm requesting you all, I,
I'm requesting you all too late,
but please make your time and come and visit us.
It would be great having you all people in our stall.
Thank you. However, Sunil is coming
and persona is coming, so I would be happy
to have them on the 19th and Teenth.
Yeah. Yeah, sure. We'll be there. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah. Okay.
So, uh, anybody else want to share something
or, uh, any questions?
All the best? Uh, yeah. Thank you sir. Thank you.
Yeah, all the best.
All the best, best. Yeah. Thank you.
Good luck. So, uh,
sir, uh, that's all, sir.
Uh, I have my screen, so thank you for the time, sir.
Thank you. Thank you, sir. Thank you all guys. Thank you.
Bye-bye. Yeah, thank you. Thank you.